was ist geräusch auch schon die bienen
ist einfach sie gerade über 3000 euro
stumpf drübergefahren
hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich war vor einigen tagen auf
einer youtube statistiken website
unterwegs und habe mir die meist
abonnierten deutschen youtube angeschaut
da waren leute wie beispielsweise dabei
wie gran wie julien berding soir in den
ganz oberen platzierungen noch einen
kanal namens härtetest mit 18,4
millionen abonnenten
es ist der meister abonnierte deutsche
youtube kanal nicht wie es bei youtube
helles sondern härtetest mit über 18
millionen abonnenten ich bin daraufhin
einfach auf seinem kanal gegangen habe
dort das hier gesehen
er lebt hauptsächlich experimente hoch
und zwar wie er mit seinem auto über
gegenstände fährt und dann habe ich den
besitzer des kanals mal eine mail
geschrieben und gefragt hey da darf ich
mir das mal einem video anschauen und er
meinte klar gern von daher let's go mit
einer reaktion auf den meist abonnierten
deutschen youtube mit 18 millionen
abonnenten das lorscher der auch noch
mit drin
minute aber was wäre denn nicht auch
dass wir brauchen halt macht um das sind
die partielle rudel nehme jetzt dann
aber doch gemacht wahnsinn lightning
mcqueen
er ist das ist ja das ist so eine
viertelstunde wenn sandra die
fahrprüfung hatte
er fährt also mit seinem auto über
sachen drüber
und ich weiß nicht warum aber ich finds
heftigkeit des fein gehört befrieden
aber anders als nächstes haben wir jetzt
hin geldes lightning mcqueen autovaz
komischerweise genauso aus wie eine tüte
ließ das
ist das denn
das band das
dass sie aus dieser mozzarella kügelchen
ich dachte erst das wäre ein golfball
gewesen aber im golf golf ball wäre auch
interessant da mal drüber zu fahren bei
einem golfball hab ich halt gar keine
ahnung was passiert also glaubt er sich
greifen wir ein drückt oder irgendwie so
die sind ja schon ziemlich hart hier
wieder über chips drüber die sind wieder
komplett ist schon heiß auf das denn
essen kuchen ein paar sekunden später
[Musik]
das war mein gehirn in der bachelor
prüfung was kraft auffällt ist dass
seine videos alle sehr sehr sehr sehr
kurzen also lädt sich irgendwie ganz
viele clips aneinander hoch und macht
die videos über zehn minuten was
werbetechnisch eigentlich sinn machen
würde sondern was das denn
was ist das
das sind dass diese was
es ist ein bisschen aus
scheiße genau erlebt er mehr videos hoch
aber dafür hat kürzere videos keine
ahnung was das jetzt richtig hunger
drauf
doch das ist ein ding ins bald der ist
jetzt voll in die luft das sind so
kleine milchpackungen hier
und wenn er denn da drüber das war mein
lieblingsspieler als kind ich finde es
irgendwie schon ziemlich set ist verein
auf der anderen seite denke ich mir aber
auch sonst ein bisschen ekelhaft jetzt
gerade auch weil ja gut das war auf
jeden fall das erste video was uns
angeschaut haben das ist aber auch schon
ein bisschen älter machen wir es weiter
mit diesem video jeder fährt er als
allererstes über wasser
was soll denn war das nicht so richtige
griechenland-urlaub sonnenbrillen so er
eigentlich kosten die 100 euro aber für
dich heute nur 50 cent aber nur heute
also ich weiß nicht wirklich wie er sich
dann morgens aufsteht und denken heute
drehe ich mal ein video über was für
euch heute macht er sich dann eine liste
interessant jetzt braucht jetzt über
millipore
mikey way bin ich dumm sollten monte
gewesen oder wasserfall hier wieder am
start dieser kanal zeigt mir halt
einfach wie viele kanäle es wirklich
gibt die in deutschland gegründet werden
aber ich mag der konten in denen also
dem verschiedenheit auf jeder sprache
das egal ob du als englisch französisch
spanisch oder deutsch spricht aber dass
[Musik]
das ist mein neuer lieblingsclub das mal
an
wien ist das denn
ich könnte mir sowas wirklich den ganzen
tag anschauen was ich gerade noch sagen
wollte auch wieder eine neue wasser -
audi hat er nicht richtig getroffen
aber was ich gerade sagen wollte war das
nicht so krass findet wie viele kanäle
ist wirklich gibt in deutschland die
mehr abonnenten haben jetzt irgendwie
alte gewiss youtube l ist ja die meisten
abonnierte ist wenn man sich
beispielsweise auch mal friedlich das
anguckt oder crazy frog ist glaube ich
auch in deutscher kanal oder härtetest
hier 18 millionen so krass 18 millionen
abonnenten und ist einfach ein deutscher
typ so der kanal ist übrigens runde in
der beschreibung verlinkte das frage ich
mich was es ist
dieses blaue ist das so knete das war
auch ein gesetz auch bei mir ganz oben
mit dabei auch da hätte ich jetzt auch
wieder hunger drauf das ist auch gemein
dass ich mir sowas angucken wenn ich
hungrig bin machen allerdings hier
weiter mit einem video war aber ein
brandneues iphone finden
[Musik]
ich dachte erst das wäre ein fake iphone
aber schaut mal wenn wir jetzt die
gruppe fährt das ist der homescreen und
jetzt hier ist ein anderer screen
also du kannst du im internet wirklich
so fade handys kaufen und die auch schon
den homescreen drauf haben dann einfach
ein bisschen led beleuchtung wie du aber
nicht bedienen kann es aber hier ist er
halt realtech über ein echtes iphone
gefahren das hier ist diese folie bauer
das war einmal so nah ist wenn man sich
was bestellt hatte man hat immer also
für mich war es immer mehr spart diese
blubberblasen der kaputt zu machen als
das paket schnitt ich habe es so hunger
ist käse darüber die erste bodies platte
platzen alle richtig auf und noch kommen
kann ich drüber am ende
ich finde es auf jeden fall hart konzert
ist frei natürlich kann man jetzt in
frage stellen er fährt hier bei
süßigkeiten drüber und das können andere
menschen essen und so weiter und so fort
aber altar das ist auch nicht gut für
ein reifen der väter durch scherben
durch das denke ich mir auch so hey was
hat er denn für ein auto as rom houben
hätten wir die auto frage auf jeden fall
auch geklärt also es ist ein relativ
alter renault auf jeden fall erfährt
jetzt hier über iphones zu bauen nicht
nur bei einer sondern er hat wirklich
mehrere verschiedene der titel dieses
videos ist many iphones versus k also
eher diesem komplett neu und die
funktionieren
die katze mir auch schlecht das sind
einfach sieben brandneue iphones über
die die jetzt drüber verwenden und ist
geräusch auch schon liegen sie ist
einfach die sie gerade über 3000 euro
stumpf drübergefahren jetzt sprüht er
das ganze nochmal zurück ab und wir
sehen die iphones werden wieder ganz eng
das ist der moment wo die iphones noch
heile sind und spätestens jetzt denkt
sie das erste einfach auf gott oh gott
jetzt geht s los hier bisschen
stretching ja jetzt die anderen und ganz
am ende dann das neueste glaube ich
sogar mit dabei ist es gar nicht
luca wieder gar keine ahnung von technik
dieses video hier startet auf ihn aber
diesen ball
das finde ich am allermeisten wirklich
mit diesem ball hier hat er jetzt so
fußball da bin ich gespannt
okay es geht einfach die luft raus ich
dachte fußball überlegt das ganze hier
wieder reiswaffeln ich finde aber echt
mal interessant wo wir schon beim thema
überleben der produkte waren kurz
überlegt das kind einfach überlebt ich
wollte gerade diese frage im raum werfen
was denkt ihr welches produkt würde das
ganze über lebensstationen die
kommentare das kind überlebt ja ok so
backsteine und so spanplatten oder keine
ahnung was sie würden es natürlich auch
überleben aber von der zur richtigen
produkten da wäre ich echt mal gespannt
wie geht es weiter mit der liebe gott
davon habe ich vorher so geht's los
sondern klassisch oder die kamera alles
hier rein gedonnert er wird von jelly
belly tank wird so gekotzt auf einer
klassenfahrt weil ich diese kotze boden
gegessen habe naja bowie jan eumann /
wandern ich täglich genug und weiter
geht es mit einem kleinen spielzeug das
einfach ok also es gar nichts mit
passiert der luftballon ist einfach
aufgeplatzt von micky maus oder die arme
guck mal wie schnell das vor allem ging
der wagen wir hier schon wieder eine
ente er ist aber auch in nizza cannes
zackig könnte das ganze auch eine viel
größere store die kerze überlebt also
bisher großen showdown an sky sondern
die kerze war aber weiter wieder mit
einem iphone natürlich
selbstverständlich mit was auch sonst
bot hat nur ein kratzer ich bin ja auch
mal mit dem auto über ein iphone
gefahren
liga warte warte warte was den geist
funktioniert
weiter gehts wieder mit chips packungen
die sind schon so mit dem satisfied bald
sein sonst die geräusche gibt es gibt so
richtig sind von den demokraten sonne da
sind so viele sachen drin in diesem
video wo ich mir denke das hätte ich
gerade so gern zu essen also einerseits
hätten wenig später wurde ich voll bock
drauf capri sonne hätte ich voll bock
das war so typisch oh jetzt später
wieder zurück auch interessant immer das
dann noch mal so in die luftballons
reingehen zu sehen guck mal jetzt jetzt
los
alter
und dann
wird
und bahnen
oder nächste auch noch und der nächste
doch das bisschen aus wie das sagen sie
aus wie ein tornado aber ich habe
absolut keine ahnung von
naturereignissen du bist du dumm junger
alter du bist so cool machen wir weiter
mit zahnpasta in luftballons
[Musik]
ich dachte die luftballons sind dran
damit die zahnpasta da halt rein geht
aber es hat sich gelöst
das war richtig feuer aus bei der
zahnpasta mal anschauen erfährt darüber
wie wird sich diese einfach alles so
raus wie man kann mich da sind noch
viele neider ausgeht alles so rein
einmal kann sie mit nicht mit so
leichten dummen sachen kann man mich
einfach beeindrucken und vergnügen
das hörte sich als falsch hier sehen wir
wieder joghurt ey das ist doch gemein
ich habe sogar man kann nicht wieder
über irgendwelche golfbälle fahren oder
spielzeuge oder so jetzt wieder über
dieser ort das bin ich ja krass mit den
scherben das finde ich ja immer etwas
und kinder trauern zerstört kinder
überraschungseier sogar mit spielzeug
drin hier wieder über so eiscafés drüber
hierüber sie das ok wat was ist das denn
dass diese süßigkeiten oder sind das
tiefgefrorene karotten kroketten man ich
kann mir nicht reden und so wird will
ich an der stelle das heute geht jetzt
auch beende meine lieben freunde wie
bereits zu beginn des videos gesagt ich
habe mir einfach mal die meist
abonnierten deutschen youtube klagen der
schotte und härtetests war mit 18 4
millionen abonnenten auf der
unangefochtene nummer eins deswegen hab
ich mir gedacht schauen wir uns nochmal
an womit er 18,4 millionen abonnenten
hat ich finde es extrem zäh des verein
in diesem video sich können wir das
jetzt noch stundenlang anschauen wie hat
euch gefallen schon gerne in die
kommentare abonniert main kanal falls
doch kein teil der luxury seit und jetzt
befinden wir uns auch schon im auto
meiner lieben freunde hier oben findet
ihr ein smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr
noch kein teil der luftseite main kanal
noch nicht abonniert habt gibt dort oben
gern drauf roth 18,4 millionen
wir müssen härtetest den rang ablaufen
riemann hin
aber jetzt das video was gestern noch
geladen habt vum tour von bibi vor
sieben jahren